weg gebaut
ja okay ich bin jedoch dabei der kiste
ich auch okay halt echt geile sachen
dann behalte einfach die rüstung
erschweren auch behalten ich glaube
müssen uns noch eine zweite kiste machen
kann man ohne zweifel ich habe ja kein
holz gerade auch kein holz mehr wie ich
kurz hoch beide brauchen noch ein
bisschen holz so da mache ich mir schon
meine reisen
diese verzauberten hass zu helfen ich
denke er stirbt so a ha so ich habe
jetzt alle eine komplette ausrüstung
dann das nächste reise was ich hab ja
sogar noch viel eisen dann kann ich da
noch was geben die schuh kannst du mal
ich hab nämlich ja die hose habe ich
schon als verzaubertes frage ist das
holz stadtwald ich auch erst mal so ich
habe auch genug mit ein paar sachen in
der kiste ich habe jetzt noch genug holz
für zwei weitere kisten und wer wirklich
uns komplett ausstatten können ich hab
hier noch erde kreml bilde das braucht
es nicht
hast du pilze gefunden und also nur
braune hast du holz weil wir brauchen
wirklich nur abgefunden im genug für
zwei kisten guter macht noch eine
daneben am besten
was du da ist platz für so was brauche
ich nicht
ich kann dir noch 66 eisen geben daraus
kannst du dir dann irgendwie einen helm
machen oder kanada machte mir schnell
ein helm war ich bin gar um ein
sortieren alles das kann man sich dann
am besten mit 6 1 und machte helmes
wirklich was einzig im plastik noch eine
nächste kiste hinstellen und zwar eine
die heldenhafte sachen beinhaltet
ich habe dann helm hingeschmissen dann
könnte man als eine die wirklich geile
sachen beinhaltet zb kranke oder so wir
später nicht alles aussuchen müssen wir
die schadens denke einfach dass das gold
noch ne ich brauche jetzt einfach noch
das gold damit du den vielleicht noch
ein brustpanzer machen kannst oder so
ist aber hier nochmal mich nur weizen
redstone fackeln ab und ok gut ich
glaube ich gehe noch mal für 12 und
gerade mich jetzt hier nochmal in so
einen gang rein genau weiß habe ich ja
jeden quatsch wieder eingepackt nicht
mehr egal sollst du das einfach mal dass
er erst mal relativ egal wie weit aber
die immer sachen da die ganzen 100
es ärgert mich dass wir noch keine
richtigen diamanten gefunden haben wir
sind ja eigentlich echt gut aufgestellt
ja eigentlich schon aber ich glaube die
anderen wirklich diamanten schon so ich
suche einfach jetzt mal oben weiter ist
die erste folge schon vorbei noch nicht
oder ja doch die erste ist glaube ich
schon vorbei noch schneiden müssen wir
schon machen ich glaube es hat da ja ein
hat 15 minuten in chat geschrieben
da müssen wir einfach schneiden man ja
mit blüten ca danach alles ganz
entspannt
ich glaube es auch mal in die andere
richtung vielleicht ist dann auch nur
burg weil er meinte das soll es ja
mehrere von geben als er wieder auch
kein weg punkt gesetzt
manchmal schnell
wie geht das noch mal mdv internet kiste
das ist so geil ich habe zum ersten mal
jetzt hier von nord auf die dienste
bekommen die minimap ich habe niemals
benutzt und die ist ja wirklich sexy die
ist richtig geil vor allem man kann ja
auch noch auf iks drücken und dann sieht
man so eine mega map das ist traumhaft
das habe ich nie so wirklich
kennengelernt und ich bin hin und weg so
stimmt bei der mini map da kannst du
vielleicht auch diesem thema finden naja
ich find ja auf jeden fall die häuser
mit einem mini map ja diese darauf
gezeichnet aber ich weiß nicht ob der
turm auch wirklich drauf ist musst du
einfach am besten lässt wirklich wenn du
das noch mal rein geht noch mal schauen
ob da nicht noch mehr sachen drin sind
aber der turm der war schon echt
abgelassen meld dich zum bosque muss
also ich hab schon unten auf der
untersten ebene alles weg gesammelt war
ja vier kisten oder so dicke im laptop
man nehme ich find ich keine diamanten
ist echt ärgerlich
ich glaube hier wie überall schon jemand
schaut euch einfach noch ein bisschen um
was es noch so wichtig vielleicht lasse
ich kann gut mit dem bogen umgehen
ja eigentlich ich bin schon ganz gut mit
dem boden dann versucht irgendwie
spinnen zu töten wegen der wieder mit
seinen gefühlen gefunden es war die
spekulationen wieder hochklettern können
und ich sehe ein spieler aber wir dürfen
uns nicht bekämpfen
den habe ich mir lieber abnehmen
bekämpfen dürfen uns aber noch nicht als
es eigentlich relativ egal aber wenn die
da sind darauf sich schon alles ja
umgegraben dort nehme ich mal stark an
bestimmt sag es gehört das sagen dass
wir zu anfang erstmal relativ defensiv
vorgehen und die anderen sich erstmal
punch lassen
so ist das ist mal die beste taktik ich
bin eine vielfalt von dem versierten ein
clip bekommen und zwar in einem grünen
sollen geile items versteckt sein
check das schau am besten man minecraft
abgeschmiert
da muss einfach wieder
neu starten schnell will ich war gerade
unter wasser jetzt mein spiel herunter
gerutscht ist 9
wo ist die ip da aber hier steht er den
der kev letzte game also müsstest du an
genau der stelle wieder drin sein ich
auch selbst sagt und ob hier mein laptop
man mich ist das eine ich kann mich die
ganzheitliche pampa und ich bin einfach
keiner diamanten dass das ist wirklich
ärgerlich und unglücklich ein so da bin
ich wieder so weit unten
ok jetzt bin ich wieder da und ich
glaube man verdeckt hier hast du scheiße
ich sehe auch gar nichts dann gern das
nicht das loch stirbst nehmen ihnen die
da unten ist auch gar nicht wie ich das
grab auf dem fahrrad statt tipp ich habe
gesehen den boden habe ich noch gesehen
und da war nix scheiße da gehe ich aber
da ist noch einen grund wirklich auch
noch mal hin und ich habe ich ein
spanner darf den abbauen lerne ja das
alles ab und glich erfahrung nämlich für
meine erfahrung bringt nix scheiße wir
bräuchten verzögerungs tisch aber dafür
bauern jammern ist teuer der
verzauberung stick baby und brandi hier
vorne auch wenn lena und stark sind ja
glaube ich zusammen
die nation erst offen ist dann auch wir
hier ist ja noch jemand urlaub und luke
und der hat ihr bestimmt alles abgegrast
der norder produkte werden
wahrscheinlich gewinnen dass diese fonds
sondern gehe ich mal weiter auf einem
kleinen boot ist auch sohnemann muse
baumann ich will ja man ich finde die
neuen fans aber nur königlich
dem motto nie richtig kennengelernt
ich will diamanten gehe ich sicher die
improvisierte außenmauer app welt ist
wirklich klein
ich hätte mal bock das einfach so mal zu
zocken weil das ist ja hier sind pilz
jump and run
ich finde die ganze zeit eisern was
bringt ja nix schon eine komplette
rüstung habe aber ich hab nur damit du
hast du schon passen noch keine
ich habe erst die hose und hellem ja
dann bringe ich das einfach mal für dich
mit schaden kann's ja nicht nur ich
würde auch sagen dass jetzt langsam
wieder zurück kommst du da erwarte ich
so noch mal konnte ich mir was schon
einmal komplett rum also ich hab den
halben halbkreis schon fast komplett
etwas angeht
dann kommen noch mal ja dann kommen noch
mal zurück und sucht dann am besten auch
noch diamanten mit mir das wäre ich da
mal wenn wir zwei diamanten finden
würden das war schon genial ist nur ein
diamantenvorkommen das ist echt krass
ich hab 37 als das reicht das recht
locker oh mein gott ich würde vielleicht
sollte ich mich ja hier mal runter
graben und dann schauen oder weil noch
mal das zurücklaufen das wäre ja sagen
verschwendete zeit oder nicht aber du
musst so oder so später zurück laufen
das jetzt oder gleich da stimmt neue die
markierung bisschen komisch dass er
wirklich unglücklich außerhalb der
markierung ist heute gar nicht gesehen
ich kann auch diese fliegenpilz abholen
großen oder ja macht er war ich davon
nämlich ein paar ab dann weil mich essen
ja man kann auf eine so was von
schnitzeln ab jetzt ein paar abgeordnete
schnell so habe ich vier plätze ein
bisschen wenig walter ich bin nur am
graben ich finde einfach keine diamanten
so zackig komme ich nochmal zurück man
aber das ist man findet hier aber auch
für oberfläche gar nicht wie ich das
sehe haben alle also jeden den ich
bisher getroffen habt ihr an beide
gegraben jeder sucht halt irgendwie
diamanten kann man sich dann aus eisen
noch so alles machen nicht kessel ja
vielleicht sollten fix von lava immer
mitnehmen
ja stimmt klar war ja komm ich jetzt
wieder zurück wir haben jetzt noch
vielleicht drei minuten kisten
also ich bin gleich wieder da
wer ich bin wieder zurück das sehe ich
wölfe die greifen würde ihr an nicht
wolf merzig bei den 100 alle die bei mir
zuschauern ja ich hab das eisen extra
basieren weil ich habe 40 also das recht
locker nein ich hab und angeblich alle
an alter [ __ ] [ __ ] werde stirbt nein der
da kann nicht schwimmen
porschen auf preußen ja stimmt das wieso
ich müsste essen das passt doch
ich sterbe nicht hab sogar mein herz
voller und gegen vier wölfe so war eine
geht's wieder los
traumhaft kommst zurück ja ich bin jetzt
nur noch 100 meter 150 entfernt ungefähr
stöhnte schon so müsste es mich sogar
fast schon sehen so viel stein und soll
das ist unglaublich
wir haben echt viel müsste sein graben
weil es mal richtig hardcore here at
work effect of eclipse attacke ich habe
gerade meine special night vision
einfach weggeworfen 98 die ist ja doch
die müssen wir gleich mal nehmen wenn
wir nicht jemanden suchen wir keine
fackeln ja aber in zwei minuten ist er
vorbei also dann ist nichts mehr mit
jemanden suchen achso und ab dann ist
immer nur noch in sneek modus ist klar
schnell ein graben und da ich jetzt
genug er damit hat mein reschen aufsicht
häuschen wie thomas bastian wie kann man
eine posten zu einer session
wir brauchen ein krieg also ein ja ist
dass die noch streng pulver haben wir
nicht verfehlt finden war bestimmt ja
aber werden nur noch zwei minuten das
heißt langsam kommt meiner kiste da das
eisen drin in der kiste in den ofen wird
da und daraus kann sie jetzt einfach
noch richtung machen
ich war neun stück glaube ich ne also da
kann ich den hut die sachen klein 8
es gibt immer bitte zwei alten wenn du
hast hier habe ich dort nicht nur noch
in richtung gemacht
das habe ich okay die stiefel sollte ich
auch verändern wenn wir die zwei reisen
einfach raus was schon meerwasser ich
habe 11 so stieg tnt ist noch welche
sticks ist das alles nicht die loher
route man kann hier bestimmt irgendwas
kraft nicht wette mit
ich habe zwei reisen schwerter so ich
bin eigentlich schon vorbereitet für den
kampf es ist ein laib brot bis so schön
vorbereitet von kampf ich brauche noch
vier eisen habe ich hier tue ich das mal
hier rein das tnt dass ich hab mir das
verzauberte schwertner
so geht apple leerer kassen apps tx
dabei also ich hab zwar stiefel aber die
feder von stiefel die bei euch nicht nur
zack zack zack
linda jetzt habe ich auf die schiefe
frieden ist vorbei ich habe gefragt wann
es losgeht
ich glaube aber noch mal schnell wir
können ja fliegen und graben das ist ja
drei minuten noch ok hab ich hier bin
ich hier
11 so ich gehe jetzt um grade weil so
wird uns keiner muss auf dauer tragbar
ich werd ich habe hier eigentlich bin
ich perfekt vorbereitet ich hab's
schwerter ich habe essen
ich habe auch eine spitzhacke und
schreibt eine rüstung ich habe
ordentlich überlege ich glaube ich nehme
jetzt noch als und hoffen dass dieser
lava quelle da genauer noch mit am
besten auch da man eben einmal voll
stimmt das kennt man ja aber ich weiß
nicht wie viele männer machen kann das
ist der neue lover quelle da gewesen
probieren geht über studieren wenn es
zwei gegen zwei wenn nicht dann halt nur
ein
ich muss doch ein paar fackeln mitnehmen
wird echt oster oder soll ich mir den
transport zwischen geben will ich noch
nicht machen wird fackeln mit dem
batterie hälfte der fackeln geben ich
habe 42 und bleibt stehen einfach selbst
zugeworfen perfekt und attacke sie war
ja schon
ja ich war schon fast überall und ich
habe nie etwas gefunden ich habe wieder
nur eisen aber das finde ich wirklich
was war sogar massig eisen aber dass uns
der regel aber fit zu bekommen
er ist gut okay das eine spinne wir
haben eine spinne sei dafür braucht man
das noch mal da sind komische koblenz
spinnenseide vermögen haben wir schon
ein bogen pakistan komme schon was geht
da hab ich das geld liegt auf schöne
ganze zeit oder baus daran auch richtig
zu dass keiner uns findet ja mache ich
gleich hier war noch ein zombie irgendwo
her
ach du scheiße komm schon ich habe mal
kurz etwas leiser das extrem laut matt
muss was das denn das ist diese sounds
die dort benutzt ach so ist es schwer
ist die ganze zeit davon
ja ich dachte das wäre so hinzugefügt
so hatte er hier die slava ding ist das
klettern
ich gab mich hier im zickzack durch die
gegend um meine chancen zu erhöhen aber
offensichtlich berlins das alles nichts
lustig da minuten lang durch gegraben
hier die fenster rein gar nichts einfach
okay jetzt laufe ich weiß nicht ich
nehmen kann man vor so erstmal ohne
hülle ist hier nehmen man kann nicht nur
einnehmen eingang unten kripo aber der
wurf frank klauss dann versuchen
wirklich zu kennen sie bestimmt noch
einer
also hat die diamanten nicht erwischt
ich habe mich zehn milliarden jahre
dadurch freilich weil ich fünf diamanten